Nicola bully was last seen on Friday
morning walking her dog near the river
wire in Lancashire after dropping her
children off to school five days in and
police continued their search
focusing around the bench where her dog
and Nicholas phone were found according
to her partner still attached to a work
conference call in a statement today
Lancashire police said we remain
extremely concerned for Nicola and we
continue to do everything we can to try
and find her and to provide some answers
for her family who were obviously beside
themselves with worry
adding this remains a missing person
inquiry and at this time there is
nothing to suggest any third-party
involvement in Nicola's disappearance
this is a small picturesque Lancashire
town and alongside the extensive police
search the community here has come
together to do what it can to try and
help find the missing mum of two
her family and friends are devastated
you go from being hopeful to being
heartbroken to being and just trying to
be strong because all we want is to find
her she's got two little girls wanting a
mummy so anybody's got any any
information please just come forward we
don't know what why she's missing where
she is we just want her home
friends tell us Nicola bully was a
much-loved active member of this small
community
her family say her daughters are just
desperate to have mummy home Catherine
avatarsi Sky News in Lancashire